we haven't done anything we're a totally
peaceful racist group we're a peaceful
group we wanted to have a peaceful
meeting celebration of life at the
crusader Park we're tapped by rate as
racist and you councilmen all you you
pulled the race card in the very first
paragraph of our website in Nashville
straight pride coalition org we say were
there to defend all races and colors you
pulled out Caucasian you didn't have any
ramifications after which we put in our
in our and our manifesto per se you
attack this is racism you pulled the
race card to pull in attacks against to
justify attacks against us in that Park
and when they come you're gonna turn
right around and say well we've deserved
it we haven't done anything we're a
totally peaceful racist group
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
colors life started the natural I
started the war line whites against
racism alliances that will work again
[Music]
now we will have respect to all speakers
in the room near all speakers